foreign
Elder has been in California media
forever telling the truth in a really
smart and sometimes hilarious way
he just ran for governor of California
in a recall election against Gavin
Newsom he came up short after the
state's media United to call him a white
supremacist
still makes us laugh it's pretty
offensive actually but he's not deterred
he has a major announcement for us
tonight our friend Larry Elder joins us
now Larry thanks so much for coming in
so I'm sorry and I'm sorry to laugh at
that I'm sure it's hard for you to laugh
at but it's just it's so insane
um so what are you up to next
but Tucker you almost have to laugh at
it it's so ridiculous and actually the
the actual quote was Larry Elder is the
black face of white supremacy Tucker and
the sub headline was you've been warned
by the way one other LA Times columnist
referred to My Views as white
supremacists why because I'm pro-life
because I don't buy the notion that
America is systemically racist because I
want to cure borders because I want us
to be energy uh in independent instead
of energy dependent because I know that
our Urban schools are a disaster so for
all those reasons I was called the black
face of white supremacy and a white
supremacist in terms of my views my
announcement Tucker
is I'm announcing that I'm running for
the presidency of the United States on
your program and thank you so much for
giving me this honor in this platform my
website is elderforpresident.com
elderforpresident.com
and talking the reason I'm doing this is
because you know my father was a World
War II vet he served in in on the island
of Guam he was a Marine
first Black Marines are called Montford
Point Marines my older brother my late
older brother Kirk was in the Navy
during the Vietnam era and my little
brother Dennis actually served in
Vietnam in the Army I'm the only one who
didn't serve and I don't feel good about
that I feel I have a moral a religious
and a patriotic duty to give back to a
country that's been so good to my family
and to me and that is why I'm doing this
Tucker
well it's that's amazing congratulations
it's a big decision to make I I very
familiar with your views I think I agree
with all of them pretty much but if you
were to narrow it down just pick one or
two the issues that are animating you
that are making you feel like you've got
to put everything on hold and do this
what are they well aside from the
obvious things about the borders I
mentioned before the crime the the
maligning of the police there are a
couple of things that I think our side
does not spend enough time talking about
and that is the LIE the absolute
disgraceful lie that the Democrats put
on everything which is that America is
systemically racist it isn't just a lie
Tucker it's having real consequences the
police are pulling back it's called the
Ferguson effect or the George Floyd
effect and the people who are who are
harmed by that are the very black and
brown people that people on the left
claim they care about there's been a
study that shows hundreds if not
thousands of people are now dead because
the police are not engaging in proactive
policing because they've been
demoralized by people calling them
racist the second thing tuckery is
the 10 000 pound elephant in the room
regarding all of this stuff we see uh in
Chicago and some of these other cities
with these Mass mobs is the lack of
fathers in the home right now today in
America 40 percent of all kids enter the
world without a father in the home
married to the mother seventy percent in
the black community 50 of Hispanics 25
percent of whites now that's the same
percentage as was the case of blacks
back in 1965 the question we should be
asking ourselves is how do we go from
having 25 of black kids entering the
world in 1965 without a father in the
home a married to the mother to 70 today
and the answer is the welfare state
we've incentivized women to marry the
government we've incentivized men to
abandon their financial and more
responsibility and if I do nothing else
in this race but Focus people on those
two issues I will have I would have
performed this service to my country
did you I know that my father had had
the pivotal effect on my life was that
true for you did your dad have an effect
on the man you became absolutely and my
father never knew his biological father
so it's not a death sentence but my
father believed in hard work he ended up
working when he got out of the military
two full-time jobs cleaning toilets
Tucker started a little cafe when he was
around 47 years old ran it until his 80s
and my dad died he owned the property
where the restaurant was a little piece
of property next door to it plus a house
from South Central that we still have in
our own family so the man had died with
a net worth of a little bit under a
million dollars not too bad for a kid
from Athens Georgia Jim Crow South whose
mom threw him out of the house at the
age of 13. that's what you can do in
America my dad by the way was a lifelong
Republican he said this about Democrats
Democrats want to give you something for
nothing when you try to get something
for nothing you almost always end up
getting nothing for something and my mom
was a lifelong uh if I said Democrat I
meant Republican my mom was a lifelong
Democrat and Tucker they would have
arguments over the kitchen table but
nobody called anybody a fascist nobody
said you only care about the rich nobody
said can you only care about the poor
they were able to debate these things
civilly and we had to be able to do that
in this country amen
that's well that's that's a really
inspiring message Larry Elder
congratulations on this decision I'm
glad you made the announcement here and
we'll see you again thanks I appreciate
it for president.com subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight